I love that almost all of David's movies
deal with uh what we call now a toxic
masculinity and maybe throughout history
we're just the either evil or induced
evil whims of men I'm not my father you
know when Dave explained to me the
language wasn't the same here and this
was the attempt at getting a searing
portrait of the young man in
circumstance That's too great for him
with a skill set and a level of
experience and a level of political
experience and familial experience that
is no good for the circumstances at hand
this assassin you send can be taken as
nothing other than an infant Act of rule
to get to do this at a young age jump in
with people that are best at their craft
just go in it's it's a felt like a
no-brainer I must leave you now
[Music]